celebrities at movie premieres always
get asked the same vapid showbiz
questions so I decided want to ask him
something different get ready to play
softball my ball was just mean unique
about this role in in terms of what this
couple goes through the way in which Kim
has depicted this marriage in its
fractious state I think that the
intertwining of all of those things and
ideas is really difficult there's a
climate change conference coming up what
do you think that the leaders should
talk about when it comes to helping the
calls are Australians are we thank you
important question tell me lo you still
mean the outback I love getting out into
the into those space of Australia what
do you think about the free trade
agreement trans-pacific partnership do
you think it's gonna help the middle
class in Australia or is it going to
code it I'm generally not that
interested in free trade agreements free
trade agreements generally her generally
good for the most powerful person in
that agree
they're not going to agree to it
otherwise so certain people are going to
lose out to look at again Australia what
do you think that that your person
should do about the extermination and
extinction of coral reef that is due to
climate eight I don't know what the
answer is but I guess the first step is
awareness and making people aware that
there is a serious problem and that it's
a whole big the whole world comes one of
the wonders of the world and if we don't
all do something to save it we're all
going to one of those wonderful world
what are your thoughts on these on
Europe and the US counterterrorism
strategy do you think the militarism is
the way to go I think it's a lot about
disenfranchised and dislocated young men
and women who are slightly outside of
the of the system in in countries and I
think there is a fanaticism which is
kind of rain washed those who are
looking for I don't know our way back I
think a lot of people feel may be
bullied or something but it's an extreme
part of a beautiful religion think you
know the strategy is you know is to is
to have dialogue I think the dialogue is
the strategy are your thoughts on all
black lives matter I know I'm the
movement going on I'm just not the one
to ask you a question like that I don't
really have any intelligence you say
level
the line is between investment in
exploitation when it comes to let's say
oil exploration in Nigeria well that's a
massive question I mean and the question
I can't possibly begin to answer right
now but but i would simply pointed to
the great work from the MEI clothes even
like the late seventies done by ken saro
we were in nigeria and any ideas of
shale oil post-civil war in Nigeria or
so but it's honestly just too massive
for this context
you